hey reject nation I'm Greg Alba and I'm
cat Alvarado cat Alvarado is here today
so I can tell you guys to catch her on
television that's right folks your local
tube it is on the FNX channel link in
description box from what FNX is Friday
at 9 p.m. Pacific Standard Time 23rd
March 23rd yeah because if this is
you're watching this video after March
23rd not applicable to you hopefully
you're watching this beforehand make
sure to catch her there that's me
top 10 scary Japanese urban legends
let's do it ken and I like to watch
these like scary list videos or creepy
stuff she was telling me how she listens
to certain horrifying podcasts so I'm
like this is the perfect guest to have
to watch us with I'm a murder ito
shout-out to any murder he knows out
there it's a murder Reno it's someone
who likes a certain podcast this is like
a little secret message stay sexy and
don't get murdered you guys okay to be a
murderer in here this is from a channel
called as a new channel I haven't seen
in other videos most amazing top-10 but
this was sent to us on Facebook it's
laughable another scary video this is a
legend series where we take a look at
traditional and modern stories from
countries all around the world always
different always varies 3 Peter my name
is Danny Burke and this is the top 10
scary Japanese urban legends starting of
another 10 that we have tech tech this
is the urban legend about a girl who
fell under a train and was cut in half
she then became a well spirit the moves
using her hands and elbows dragging
herself while making the sound tech 10
if you hear that noise you're supposed
to just run for your life those who are
caught by the tech tech or a scene of
fate just like hers she said to slash
her be altered half so that they look
like her and possibly also become
wandering vengeful spirits just like she
is now we have the slit-mouthed woman
you may recognize this one from a number
of Japanese movies and TV shows the
traditional name for this being is
cookie sucky honor
it's back over 300 years ago she's a
woman it was brutally murdered by her
husband after he found out that she was
having an affair with another samurai
this left her in death as a restless
vengeful spirit she has said to cover
her mouth with a cloth mask a fan or a
scarf she'll ask you if you think she's
pretty
if you answer yes she will then remove
the mask and when the victim screams
they will be slashed from ear to ear
until they look like her even if you say
no to this question she said to just
follow you home and then brutally murder
you that night rhinos registration
daruma-san
this urban legend is more of an old game
that's been passed down through the
years so here's how it goes you show up
in a bath you turn out the light a new
chant daruma-san fell down oh right the
show hair it said that you will then see
a woman in your mind
she is the rumors that she'll be
standing up in the back you will see her
slip and fall into an old rusty tap it
goes straight till so then you will feel
her ghostly presence somewhere behind
you now if you turn around there she
will be black tangled hair rotting close
one eye is blood shot and the other is
just a bloody hollow eye socket the game
continues even further mat game day but
I could have some rough videos to
understand just how creepy this urban
legend is okay and the seven that we
have the girl from the gap it's Japanese
story okay people's natural fear of what
lies lurking in the cracks of a home do
you guys ever see something move past
the hinge of a door when the door is
open is that similar looking at no sign
of it whatever have pictured hand
reaching out from between your bed and
the floor completely girl from the gap a
spirit that lives both physically and
metaphorically between worlds it's said
that if you ever see her she will ask
you if you want to play hide and seek at
that point the game is on when you see
her between a gap again she'll drag you
to an otherworldly hell another six now
we have at the Red Room this is a very
modern Japanese urban legend about a
pop-up ad it's all red and black when
you see it
Charles voice it will simply repeat the
phrase do you like parently a boy who
got the pop-up tried to close it but it
just kept tripping
it changed to do you like red keeps
trying to close it but it grows larger
and changes again to say do you like the
Red Room then the site changes entirely
it's just completely red and black it
has a list of names on it his friend's
name is at the bottom I haven't reaches
out towards the boy's neck from a video
anything gets even more twisted but
guess what it's based on a real website
it's still out there
you can find it you'll know de gruesome
legend of the Red Room and the horrible
ending comes true for you invader back
to ancient times in Japan where it's
known as hito bashira back then there
was a belief that a human sacrifice seal
inside a structure would make the
foundation more stable this means that
many old Japanese buildings are set to
contain the spirits of the people who
was sacrificed during their construction
one famous example is matsue castle
where a woman was sealed inside the
Foundation's during its construction now
her spirit is said to haunt the castle
and whenever a woman dances there the
castle shakes violently many builders in
Japan are actually quite open about
their buildings being a human to pick up
the baby to help they find it's not
actually a child at all the bundle then
becomes very heavy and stops the victim
from fleeing the snake woman then uses
her long tongue to suck all of the blood
from the victim's body until they die
through now we have Ani
Babur she is a demon woman that often
appears in Japanese folklore even she
men appear as an old woman asking for
help when you get to the tormented
spirit woman who accidentally killed her
own pregnant daughter and unborn
grandchild in an effort to find a cure
for her friend's child being sick she
was told to bring back the liver of an
unborn child but when she finally killed
her victims
she found they were actually her own
okay next up a number two now we have
the dream school this one is extra
creepy because apparently if you don't
forget this story within a week of
hearing it it will happen to you
let's see units no that's true one night
a boy had a dream about a school the
hallways just looped forever bringing
him always back to the start
staircases led back to the first floor
as he got quite scared he heard
footsteps behind him he ran until he
found an emergency exit with a glass box
and a key next to it the glass had been
smashed and there was no key just a note
saying that it could be found in room
108 but he found that room it was empty
those students but they were backpacks
hanging off every single chair then I
was a pounding on the door he opened it
terrified to find the hallways covered
with dead children his cell never woke
up from his dream and if you don't
forget this story in one week you will
meet the same fate I'm gonna forget this
in like an alley this is truth although
you don't see me on the channel next
week sorry I'm finding the one now we
have on Rio this is a traditional
Japanese belief about a vengeful spirit
that can and will physically hurt the
living it's a very scary concept of
you're only familiar with the Western
idea of ghosts which don't really tend
to take solid forms and so can't hurt
humans with physical contact in the
traditional way that's not true though
for an unreal they are vengeful and full
of hate stopping at nothing to enact the
suffering they received when they were
alive for any of you guys who have seen
The Grudge this spirit is the influence
without prayer in that movie yeah yeah
that's now our third video exploring
urban legends around the world
we don't Korea Britain and Japan or
country or place do you want to see next
recent a lot of good suggestions in the
comment section so do hurt sweet sweet
stuff the one that really stood out to
me was the very first one they
introduced the tech tech tech creepy the
ones like walks around Drax's and yeah
she was creepy the rest sir I'm taking
stock of all the bad things I've done in
my life cuz I don't any of these go
you know it's weird as Japanese horror
movies those are the ones that will
still get to me when I watch like a J
horror film those images are the things
that really my man means Jewish a lot of
this reminded me of those like J horror
films that I've seen I keep thinking it
reminds you those kind of films in that
first one I think is a great idea like
this one just comes around slashes you
in half so she can't have you joining
the afterlife
hmm but you have a great upper half your
lower half you could do it out but your
upper half fine welcome this spirit the
tech deck crap okay yeah I think the one
creeped me out was a little woman with
the slash in her face oh yeah the night
I remembered like to talk to the best
I've heard about this one before you
think I'm pretty take it off and if
you're like oh that she kills you but if
you don't squirm or anything she'll
still kill you it's like I'm very [ __ ]
move man lady I would not be surprised
if this is based off love like a real
serial killer that actually like
happened cuz trauma is one of the things
that can cause some we become a murderer
I don't know if you knew that but that's
a thing
trauma hope that everybody who has
trauma happened to them would become a
serial killer but it's one of the causes
yes so if someone was horribly
disfigured and you know wears bitter
about it and also had a tendency towards
being a psychopath that might that's
where this yeah you have psychoanalyzed
these Japanese religions haven't you
yeah
the daruma-san that one does remind me
of like Bloody Mary you said that was a
candy man yeah and there's baby blue I
don't know when you chant that I mean I
I did like Bloody Mary when I was in
Catholic school did anything happen
no I was disappointed I ever tried a
mouse garden you should try it once you
go to my bathtub start chanting Tarzan
it'd be so cool to know your reaction to
I can record my face and do a reaction
of your death all of that video will go
viral I would do a video of the gap girl
from the girl from the gap I totally
have had that fear that someone's gonna
reach out from like under my bed and
like grab my leg or I've ever had the
fear that like something is gonna come
up from the toilet and like bite you
yeah yeah I have when I was a little kid
I usually sometimes I still do I'll just
like check the toilet this is there
anybody or anything in there so the girl
from the gap really does hone in on
those rational fears that I have the
red-room one was like alright to me just
don't visit the website you'd be fine
the houseboaters one I don't even
remember that sacrificed a person and
put their body in the foundation of a
house so that the house like per
building would be blessed okay the snake
woman snakes are one of my biggest fears
of all time you can put that on my list
of like number one biggest fears
actually so the idea of a snake woman
that's just terrifying
a most women already are snake like you
know wouldn't you agree with this
statement from an improv yes the snake
woman as the urban legend is my abusive
no Medusa has snakes for hair and in the
Bible Satan is a snake and Eve flake
talks to it okay maybe it doesn't apply
but forcing her to make a collection you
know it's all the same all beliefs are
the same
and number three what was she again oh
she like accidentally killed her own
kids oh yeah she killed her unborn
grandchild - mm-hmm but sometimes
mothers slip up man [ __ ] happens dude
he's got the dream school one sounds
like a creepy experience I don't feel
like I'll remember this story or detail
I already forgot most of it kid goes
into his class
box average dad kids I just kept
thinking like this would be cool horror
movies why aren't they all horror movies
right I feel like half of them probably
are a lot of them are definitely
inspired into some J horror films I've
seen the on on ryu is that's like The
Grudge chick for sure man taking the
physical form like that's the kind of
stuff that haunted me like I'm just
seeing these images kind of freaks me
out already like I'm afraid to go to my
balcony because they just appear out of
nowhere a better person like I really do
it won't matter
now with these urban legends they go
after the good Souls and especially the
American girls
that's what Japanese remakes into
American films have taught me they stage
never go to Japan so this video taught
me all right guys well there are there
any other urban legends you could think
from other countries that are scarier
put it in the comment boxes below
subscribe to the reel rejects click that
notification bell you know the outro cat
Alvarado is on social media catch on the
F and X Channel this Friday March 23rd 9
p.m. Pacific Standard Time performing
comedy on television videos done
you